thanks to kiwiko for sponsoring this
video
hi i'm toby and welcome to this video
where i'm going to take a little look at
the famous story alice in wonderland
written by lewis carroll it's a very
creative story
it's a bit nonsensical and at times
bizarre
but behind some of this writing there
supposedly hides a little bit of
mathematics too
you see lewis carroll is actually the
pen name for
19th century mathematician charles
dodgson
and he initially dreamed up the story
for 10 year old alice little
the daughter of his university college
dean and he told the story to her and
her sisters
on a boat trip in 1864. the fact that
carol
is much more famous as a writer than as
a mathematician
perhaps speaks to the fact that his
mathematical work was
comparatively unnoteworthy he did write
several books on mathematics
including an elementary treatise on
determinants
his work was in the fields of geometry
linear and matrix algebra
and mathematical logic so let's take a
look
at some of the math that snuck its way
into the story
after falling down the rabbit hole alice
is in a bit of distress
she says i'll try if i know all the
things i used to know
let me see 4 times 5 is 12
and 4 times 6 is 13 and 4 times 7
is oh dear i shall never get to 20
at that rate according to martin gardner
who has written an
annotated version of alice in wonderland
the most simple explanation here
is that alice is adding one every time
she does a multiplication by
four and if you keep going this way
you'll get to four times 12
being equal to 19 and children
especially
only know multiplication up to the 12s
so she won't be able to go any further
and won't be able to get to 20.
this is a nonsense form of
multiplication
but it sets us up for the nonsense to
come later in the story
we meet the cheshire cat all right said
the cat
and this time it vanished quite slowly
beginning with the end of the tale
and ending with the grin which remained
some time after the rest of it had gone
well i've often seen a cat without a
grin
thought alice but a grin without a cat
it's the most curious thing i ever saw
in all my life
this grin might be referring to abstract
or
pure mathematics that it doesn't
necessarily have a cat to go along with
it
which would be the real life
applications or even
obvious uses of what the research
mathematicians are working on
they're doing it just for the joy of the
mathematics itself
and are living in the abstract world of
the equations
further into wonderland alice is talking
to griffin
and mock turtle she asked them about
lessons
and how many hours a day did you do
lessons said alice
in a hurry to change the subject ten
hours the first day
he said the mock turtle nine the next
and so on
what a curious plan exclaimed alice
that's the reason they're called lessons
because they listen
from day to day this was quite a new
idea to alice
and she thought it over a little before
she made her next remark
then the 11th day must have been a
holiday of course it was
said the mock turtle and how did you
manage on the 12th
alice went on eagerly that's enough
about lessons
this might be a fun way to introduce the
idea of negative numbers
something that also puzzled early
mathematicians
in this case what would happen on the
12th day would the students start to
teach the teacher
then we go to the famous tea party scene
there's the mad hatter
a hair and a mouse and alice is also
informed of a fourth character
time who is absent from the party due to
a falling out with the hatter
as a result the three at the tea party
are forever
stuck at tea time they're forever going
around and around the table
the hair takes out a watch and alice
remarks
what a funny watch it tells the day of
the month
and doesn't tell what o'clock it is why
should it
muttered the hatter does your watch tell
you what year it is
of course not alice replied very readily
but that's because it stays the same
year for such a long time
which is just the case with mine said
the hatter
later he says that it's always six
o'clock
is that the reason so many tea things
are put out here alice asked
yes that's it said the hatter it's
always tea time
and we've no time to wash the things
between wiles
then you keep moving around i suppose
said alice
exactly so said the hatter now it might
be nothing
but the idea of three characters start
going around and around
and not making much sense without time
shares a few similarities
with the idea of quaternions something
that was introduced
not too long before the story was
written quaternions consist of
three spatial dimensions i j and k
which are imaginary and a fourth
dimension which is
real and that is time perhaps at the tea
party
the three characters are the imaginary
units and without time
they don't really make sense a property
of quaternions
is that when you multiply them they are
non-commutative
which means the order actually matters
normal multiplication
such as 3 times 4 is the same as
4 times 3 it is commutative but with
quaternions
i times j is not the same as j times i
and there's a scene at the tea party
where this comes up in the language
they are discussing a riddle do you mean
that you think you can find out the
answer to it
said the march here exactly so said
alice
then you should say what you mean the
march here went on
i do alice hastily replied at least
at least i mean what i say that's the
same thing you know
not the same thing a bit said the hatter
you might just as well say
that i see what i eat is the same thing
as
i eat what i see you might just as well
say
added in the march here that i like what
i get
is the same thing as i get what i like
so if the characters at the tea party
are used to a non-commutative form of
multiplication
then that's maybe why they're so
unsatisfied with alice
claiming that the order of words doesn't
matter
something that happens a lot to alice
during the story is that she's often
changing size
and having to eat or drink something to
return
to the right proportions a caterpillar
even tells alice
to keep her temper and alice interprets
this to mean
to not get angry however with our
mathematical eyes in place
we could see that carol is making a play
on words
and that there is a more mathematical
definition of temper
that would have been more familiar to
victorians at the time
and has to do with scale and proportions
we see examples of both enlargements and
stretches
which affect alice's body differently we
tend to use the word enlargement
even if we're making something smaller
we would just use a scale factor
between 0 and 1 in that case and that
mathematical use of the word enlargement
might make sentences like you will grow
shorter
make a little bit more sense stretches
would act about a point
so if alice is stretched about her
middle that would make every point
twice as far away from the middle as it
used to be which might explain why her
neck grows so long
and in this case alice has lost her
mathematical temper
the caterpillar might be telling alice
to keep her body in proportion
no matter what size she is carol did
love
euclidean geometry and wrote some books
based on euclid's elements
and in euclidean geometry it doesn't
matter what the
magnitude of shapes is all that matters
is the ratio between sides or the
proportions
i have seen many other interpretations
of the alice in wonderland story
people claim to have found commentary on
social and political issues or
references
to victorian literature given the
author's background
it does make sense for there to be a
little bit of mathematics in there too
but maybe the nature of the story just
lends itself
to these interpretations regardless
i hope you've enjoyed taking a little
look down the rabbit hole
and let me know if you find any other
mathematical references yourself
if you enjoy playing with math or
finding creative ways to share science
then take a look at this video's sponsor
kiwiko
they create these super cool hands-on
projects and toys
designed to expose people to concepts in
science
technology engineering art and math
they sent me a couple of their monthly
crates i've got the make it yourself
stereo headphones and the
electroluminescent sculptures
i found the projects to contain a good
amount of creativity
and problem solving especially for
people encountering these ideas
for the first time each box comes with
all the supplies needed for that project
instructions and an educational magazine
they cater to different age groups so
you might enjoy the projects for
yourself
or know some kids who you want to share
the joy of making with
and who knows what they might go on to
do with those skills
i made a flamingo something that alice
later uses to play croquet
you can get 50 of your first month of
any crate
by going to kiwico.com tibby's
which will be linked down in the
description below a big thank you to
kiwico
and as always thanks to my patreon
supporters for helping me to make these
videos
a special shout out to today's patreon
cat of the day
xena warrior princess